[Music]
Katy Perry opens up about doing a little
soil sorry
2008 teams
[Music]
the 33 year old singer stuns on the
March cover of Glamour magazine but it's
her super candid interview about
personal growth that will really catch
your attention when asked about the last
time she was scared as hell to do
something but did it anyway
Katie revealed that she does it all the
time explaining quote and preparing to
do a big soul overhaul very soon that
I'm nervous about
I want to emotionally elevate myself she
says the goal is to grow into becoming
an adult because she's preparing to have
her own family in the near future adding
quote I want to do a little bit more
soul surgery before I have a family of
my own so that I don't transfer any of
those lingering feelings and while the
past year has been about killing her ego
Katie says it's now time to step into
being Katharine Hudson her given name
[Music]
as for dating here's the advice she'd
give her younger self quote there really
truly are so many fish in the sea you
want to end up with the cuttlefish
[Music]